Trascrizione: Luca Valenti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
"Fidarsi è bene, ma non fidarsi è meglio".
Siamo abituati a dire così in Italia, no?
Ma questo modo di pensare
veramente ci porta un mondo migliore?
Cosa ce ne facciamo, di questa paura?
E soprattutto, cosa ce ne facciamo
di questa continua mancanza di fiducia?
Da neuroscienziata, so dirvi
che come esseri umani è solito, per noi,
aver paura e respingere
ciò che è nuovo, ciò che è diverso;
e soprattutto, ciò che non è umano.
Per ricordarvi questo, vi porto a fare
un po' una passeggiata nel passato.
È il lontano 1760:
e per le strade, passeggiando,
sentiamo i fischi
delle prime macchine a vapore,
che sono state appena installate
nelle fabbriche.
Mentre l'odore pungente del carbone
invade l'aria,
noi ci avviciniamo a questa fabbrica.
E dalla porta, vediamo i lavoratori
che impauriti guardano
questi grandi, nuovi macchinari.
Hanno paura, perché queste macchine
sono molto più forti di loro,
e hanno già paura di essere rimpiazzati.
Cent'anni dopo,
la rivoluzione nell'ambito
del lavoro continua,
con l'introduzione del concetto
della produzione di massa.
Nuovamente, istintivamente abbiamo paura:
paura perché queste macchine, nuovamente,
sembrano rivolerci rimpiazzare.
Fanno tutto meglio di noi:
sono più veloci, e sono più precise.
Eppure, nel 2023, eccoci qua.
Abbiamo reinventato il mondo del lavoro
di anno in anno;
e siamo ancora qua,
circondati dalle nostre macchine.
E quindi, l'uomo di oggi
di cos'è che ha paura?
Beh, ha paura di perdere
la propria identità,
ha paura di condividere i propri dati.
O almeno, così si dice.
Perché qua, nessuno si fa problemi
a condividere 24 su 7
il proprio battito cardiaco
con una compagnia di orologi.
Nessuno si fa problemi
per il fatto che una banca, oggi,
non sa solo quanti soldi spendiamo,
ma anche: quanti caffè beviamo;
dove ceniamo;
e se smezziamo il conto, anche con chi.
Ma io non sono qua per giudicarvi:
ovviamente ho un orologio smart,
e una carta di credito anch'io:
ma sono qua per dirvi
che questo tipo di dati
sono dati personali,
perché non solo portano a noi
ma anche alle nostre abitudini quotidiane.
Quindi, se siamo disposti a condividere
questo tipo di dati con le aziende,
in cambio di un prodotto,
perché ci opponiamo a condividere
i nostri dati anonimi
con gli scienziati
e gli istituti sanitari,
che invece in cambio
ci offrono le nostre vite?
Io sono un ingegnere biomedico,
e avendo lavorato
sia nell'ambito scientifico
che in quello dell'industria
vi so dire - anzi, vi garantisco -
che condividendo
i vostri dati medici anonimi
possiamo sfruttare la tecnologia
per ottenere due grandi cose.
La prima è curare ciò che i medici
non riescono a fare;
e l'altra è salvare vite a distanza.
Siete un po' scettici?
Non pensate di avere tutto questo potere,
con i vostri dati?
Be', io ve lo dimostro.
Questo è uno scan di un cervello,
che si ottiene con una risonanza magnetica
che poi viene processata in 3D.
Immaginate quest'uomo,
che entra in ospedale dopo un incidente.
Il medico guarda questa immagine,
guarda questo scan,
e dice che sembra andare tutto bene:
i vasi sanguigni sembrano essere a posto.
Eppure, gli consiglia
di rimanere in ospedale sotto osservazione
per un altro paio di ore.
Perché questa precauzione?
Be', perché purtroppo,
anche con le tecnologie
più sofisticate di oggi,
con i macchinari più potenti,
noi possiamo vedere
soltanto i vasi sanguigni -
ovvero le vene e le arterie -
più grandi del nostro cervello,
che invece è pieno
di milioni di piccolissimi capillari
che non riusciamo
a catturare con una fotografia.
E quando questi piccoli
capillari esplodono,
causano un lento sanguinamento interno
che si può notare solo dopo ore,
con lo svenimento di un paziente
che poi solitamente viene portato
a un'operazione di emergenza.
Quindi noi cosa possiamo fare,
per preparare i medici meglio,
e per prevenire questo
malessere così evidente?
Possiamo costruire, effettivamente,
degli scanner più potenti?
Purtroppo, veramente no.
Perché abbiamo raggiunto il limite fisico
della potenza del campo magnetico
alla quale possiamo esporre
il nostro corpo umano
senza causare danni ad altri organi.
Ed è proprio qui, che entra in gioco
la mia ricerca all'Università di Oxford,
dove ho sviluppato un modello matematico -
ovvero, un algoritmo -
che serve a riempire gli spazi
che le immagini non riescono a catturare.
Ovvero, con questo modello
riusciamo a mappare, completamente,
tutti i capillari che sfuggono
sia alle macchine che ai medici.
Per costruire un modello
di questo tipo, però,
noi scienziati abbiamo bisogno
di migliaia di dati.
E questi dati li otteniamo
cercando di approcciare,
persona per persona,
volontari che vogliano condividere
con noi i loro dati anonimi.
Invece negli ospedali,
negli archivi degli ospedali,
ci sono già centinaia di migliaia
di questi tipi di immagini.
Che però, loro non possono
condividere con noi scienziati
perché i pazienti
non hanno dato il loro consenso.
Rendetevi conto di quanti soldi,
e di quanto tempo,
vengono buttati dalla comunità scientifica
per ottenere dei dati che già esistono,
ma semplicemente
non ci è permesso di usare.
Pensate a quante cure potremmo trovare
molto più rapidamente
se tutti voi, quando vi viene chiesto,
deste il consenso all'uso anonimo
dei vostri dati nel campo medico.
Ma con i nostri dati medici,
non possiamo solo migliorare la vita
e salvare vite a chi è già in ospedale;
ma possiamo, anche, aiutare
chi all'ospedale non riesce ad arrivarci.
Questa è la mappa del nostro mondo,
con un gradiente che va
dal bianco al viola.
Vi mostra il numero di ore
che una persona deve viaggiare
per arrivare all'ospedale
più vicino, in macchina.
In Europa, siamo messi molto bene:
però, se guardiamo altrove -
ad esempio in Asia,
o anche in certe parti dell'America -
le persone viaggiano per più di due ore,
per arrivare all'ospedale più vicino.
Pensate a un'emergenza:
pensate una donna in Pakistan,
con un bambino piccolo
che inizia a tossire.
E questa tosse,
di giorno in giorno, peggiora,
fino a che, a un certo punto,
il bambino fa fatica a respirare.
Al che, lei decide
di portarlo in ospedale:
lo prende in braccio,
sale su un autobus, viaggia per due ore,
arriva in un ospedale sovraffollato -
dove aspetta altre cinque ore -
solo per poi venire a scoprire
che il danno ai polmoni, ormai,
è così avanzato
da richiedere un intervento.
Che lei, tra l'altro,
non si può permettere.
Questa non è un'analogia,
che vi racconto in modo
che vi possiate ricordare questa mappa.
Questa è la storia, dell'estate scorsa,
della donna che mi ha dato questa sciarpa.
Quindi, noi cosa possiamo fare,
per aiutare lei e tantissime altre persone
che vivono in zone remote?
Costruiamo più ospedali,
in modo che non debbano
viaggiare così tanto?
Ma con che soldi?
E poi, in questi ospedali chi ci lavora,
se già nelle grandi città europee
non abbiamo abbastanza medici?
Una soluzione è la telemedicina,
che altro non è che una videochiamata
tra medico e paziente.
Immaginatevi di poter chiamare
il nostro medico a distanza -
migliaia di chilometri
di distanza, addirittura -
e fare una diagnosi.
Perché sì, la maggior parte delle volte
che consultiamo un medico di base
la nostra diagnosi è assolutamente
fattibile online, via videochat.
Pensate a quanto più semplice
sarebbe stato, per questa donna,
poter chiamare un medico
che semplicemente ascoltando
dettagliatamente
il suono della tosse del bambino
l'avrebbe potuto diagnosticare,
mandando poi digitalmente una prescrizione
per un antibiotico
che avrebbe potuto ottenere poi.
Ecco: questo è il potenziale
della telemedicina.
Ma le barriere che ci separano, dunque,
da un mondo più equo e più sano
non sono fisiche.
Perché la tecnologia c'è,
le innovazioni ce le abbiamo.
Le barriere sono dentro di noi.
È questa paura continua dell'ignoto,
che ci porta a una realtà
dove non siamo in grado
di sfruttare appieno la tecnologia,
per ottenere delle immagini migliori -
come nella neuroscienza
vi ho mostrato prima -
oppure per portare le cure
a chi accesso non ne ha.
E il grande potenziale
di queste tecnologie
non ve lo racconto solo io:
lo confermano l'80% dei medici,
che sono assolutamente convinti
che l'uso dei dati anonimi,
nel campo della medicina,
può essere di grande beneficio
per i loro stessi pazienti.
Il problema però è,
come vi ho detto all'inizio,
che chi non conosce
dettagliatamente queste tecnologie
tende ad averne una paura immensa.
Ed è purtroppo per questo
che i governi, o le persone al Governo,
sono solo all'otto per cento
nel dare il loro consenso e l'approvazione
per queste innovazioni.
La cosa meravigliosa, però,
è che una volta che i governi
sono a favore di queste iniziative,
la tecnologia medica fiorisce.
Un esempio fenomenale,
di questa collaborazione
tra scienziati e politici
è la recente pandemia del 2020.
Ai tempi, ero ancora
ad Oxford, in Inghilterra,
e con un gruppo di colleghi scienziati
volevamo renderci utili.
E abbiamo deciso di approcciare
proattivamente il Parlamento Inglese,
offrendoci da un lato
di riassumere per loro, ogni giorno,
la ricerca scientifica,
che veniva pubblicata costantemente,
per capire meglio cosa fosse
proprio questo virus;
e d'altro canto, per aiutarli a capire
come gestire l'immenso numero di pazienti
che ora sovraffollava gli ospedali.
Ed è proprio qui che il concetto
della telemedicina, in Inghilterra,
ha portato a grandi cose.
Pensate che gli ospedali in Inghilterra,
prima della pandemia,
facevano circa nove visite alla settimana
online, in videochiamata;
nel giro di poche settimane,
questi ospedali facevano 4000
visite online alla settimana!
Questo è l'esempio concreto
di una collaborazione
pragmatica, entusiasta,
verso un cambiamento
e verso un mondo più sano.
E dunque io non voglio, però,
che questi concetti rimangano
troppo astratti per voi,
o che pensate che siano
solo storie di paesi più lontani.
E quindi, pensiamo all'Italia.
E pensiamo anche all'Alto Adige,
dove un quarto della popolazione
ha più o meno sopra i 65 anni,
dove le case di riposo e gli ospedali
sono sovraffollati,
dove una visita medica
dura in media sette minuti,
perché non si ha tempo.
Se i nostri nonni, e le nostre nonne,
sono assolutamente in grado
di utilizzare degli smartphone,
perché non dare loro la possibilità
di videochiamare il proprio medico?
Difatti, la maggior parte
delle diagnosi che vengono fatte
sono assolutamente fattibili anche online,
senza il bisogno che loro
si rechino in ospedale.
Facendo così,
da un lato evitiamo
che loro perdano tempo,
stando in queste code lunghe d'attesa;
e d'altro lato minimizziamo, anche,
l'opportunità di contagiarsi.
Quindi, io dico:
i benefici sono veramente chiari a tutti;
la tecnologia c'è.
Perché aspettare?
Io non voglio aspettare.
Il mio consenso all'uso dei dati anonimi
nel campo medico lo do,
e direi che è proprio ora
di rivedere il nostro detto italiano,
dicendovi finalmente che
"Fidarsi è bene,
ma la tecnologia è meglio"
(Applausi)